it was going to be the prime minister's
Green Day in the end it was rebranded
energy security day where she sunak and
his net zero Minister was shown around a
nuclear laboratory as they launched
their plan we're going to create jobs
across the country we're going to
increase our energy security reduce
people's bills and reduce our carbon
emissions the government plan includes a
wide range of measures they're launching
an insulation scheme to make 300 000
homes more energy efficient there's a
plan to invest around 300 million
dollars in developing green hydrogen as
a fuel it's claimed to be more
environmentally friendly and there's the
formal establishment of Great British
nuclear to promote the building of new
power plants critics point out many
proposals are simply reheated versions
of old announcements and in many cases
there's no new funding for example the
government's pushing an existing 25
billion dollars investment in carbon
capture and storage removing carbon
dioxide produced by burning fossil fuels
and storing it under the North Sea many
in the energy sector are calling for the
government to use subsidies to encourage
investment in clean energy like those
President Biden's announced for U.S
firms or lose out on jobs and revenue we
were there without thinking many years
ahead of the rest of the world
but this government is just dithered and
delayed and those business opportunities
that investment will have gone to the US
it will have gone to the EU because
they've also woken up to the fact that
hydrogen
offers this huge potential just last
year the existing Net Zero strategy was
ruled unlawful and inadequate because it
didn't show how the UK would hit legally
binding carbon targets the new plan
makes much of speeding up things that
have already proved a success like
building new offshore wind farms but by
its own admission it won't reduce
household bills in the short term
creating the long promise Green
Revolution remains a long-term project
Nadine barber Al Jazeera London